hey 42 here Steven Spielberg's Jaws is
considered by many to be one of the
finest films ever made the Ferocious
Fish Fest features many iconic moments
but Spielberg himself has a personal
favorite the scene in which grizzled
shark Hunter Quint recounts the sinking
of the USS
Indianapolis in case you haven't seen it
Quint describes how in July 1945
hundreds of American Sailors were left
stranded in the chilly Waters of the
Pacific Ocean after their ship was sunk
by a jaese sub I'll save the Gory
details for later in the video but the
last line of the infamous monologue sums
things up nicely 1100 men went into the
water 316 men came out and the Sharks
took the
rest Jaws is for the most part pure
Hollywood nonsense but this particular
scene is based on entirely true events
the USS Indianapolis really did go down
in 1945 after being torpedoed by a
Japanese
submarine and thanks to a series of
monumental balls UPS on the part of the
US Navy it was four long days before the
rescue mission was launched today the
sinking of the USS Indianapolis is
widely considered to have been the
single deadliest shark attack in history
and what those Sailors went through as
the Sharks began to Circle has become
the stuff of Maritime
Legend but the story of this remarkable
ship is about much more than its Haring
demise built during peace time the
Indianapolis was The Unofficial ship of
State for Franklin D Roosevelt and when
war broke out it became the flagship of
the greatest Fleet ever
assembled after fighting in almost every
major engagement in the Pacific Theater
and miraculously surviving what should
have been certain destruction at the
hands of Japanese kamakazi Pilots the
Indianapolis was sent on one final top
secret mission one that directly
contributed to the ending of the second
World War
and changed our world forever in the
process this is the story of the USS
Indianapolis the most remarkable ship
ever to sail the seven
seas keeps is an online subscription
service that makes it easy and
affordable for men to treat their mail
pattern boldness you can get expert care
for hair loss from the comfort of your
home without ever visiting the doctor's
office or Pharmacy all treatment plans
are personalized and are aord aordable
they're typically half the cost of
traditional Pharmacy prices keeps offers
both of the FDA approved hair loss
treatment options as well as a
two-in-one gel that combines both
treatments according to clinical studies
treatments offered by keeps are 90%
effective at treating hair loss and can
increase hair growth by up to 35%
whether you're looking to prevent hair
loss stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair you have keeps
has you covered in addition to
clinically proven treatments keeps
offers hair thickening shampoo
conditioner and the styling perade which
I love most keeps customers notice
results within 6 months of star Stinger
treatment to date keeps has helped
nearly 1 million men to keep their hair
they deliver treatments to your door in
discreet packaging and shipments are
every 3 6 or 12 months and they work to
your schedule hair loss stops with keeps
for a special offer to get you started
go to keeps.com sl42 or just click the
link in the description that's ke ps.com
sl42 and a big thanks to keeps for
sponsoring this video for a vessel
that's still very much recognizable as a
modern warship it's surprising to think
that construction of the USS
Indianapolis began almost a century ago
way back in 1930 a Portland class Heavy
Cruiser the ship was 186 M long and
weighed a staggering 10,000
tons to put those numbers into
perspective the Indianapolis was twice
as long as Big Ben is tall and weighed
as much as the Eiffel Tower
like most World War II era vessels it
was steam powered and with an
operational range of a cool 15,000 miles
the Indianapolis could sail more than
halfway around the planet without
stopping to
[Music]
refuel having been born into history's
unofficial halftime break between the
two World Wars early life for the
Indianapolis was relatively sedate an
early missions saw the ship take
Franklin D Roosevelt on a tour of South
America and it was during that trip that
the president had his is crossing the
line
ceremony in case you aren't familiar
crossing the line is a tradition in many
navies that marks the first time a
rookie sailor crosses the equator at Sea
from what I can gather it's mostly an
excuse for hundreds of men to dress up
in Drag and physically assault each
other with
seawater hey whatever floats your 10,000
t booat a key feature of many crossing
the line ceremonies is a trial in which
initiates are made to prove their
seaworthiness before a mock courau
apparently not even Roosevelt most
powerful man on the planet at the time
was
exempt here you can see him aboard the
Indianapolis pleading his case before
the Royal judge of King Neptune's Court
oh no wait that's just some bloke with a
mop on his
head anyway soon enough the wigs and
lipstick had to go back into the
indianapolis's dressing up box because
across the Atlantic a Monumental
named Adolf was busy trying to burn the
entire world down
before the US entered the war the
Indianapolis was stationed at Pearl
Harbor in Hawaii yeah that Pearl Harbor
but as luck would have it on the day of
the infamous Japanese attack the
Indianapolis was bombing the crap out of
an empty Island 800 mil away as part of
a training
exercise just over 24 hours after the
Japanese poked to Pearl Harbor bear the
US officially entered the war and over
the following four years the
Indianapolis fought in almost every
major engagement in the Pacific Theater
earning 10 Battle Stars in the process
for much of that time it served as the
flagship of the most powerful Fleet ever
assembled the US Navy's fifth Fleet
under vice admiral Raymond
sprs by all accounts the Indianapolis
was well on its way to becoming one of
the most highly decorated American
warships of all time but on the 31st of
March 1945 a run in with a Japanese
kamakazi plane changed everything thing
the Indianapolis had been bombarding
Beach defenses at okanawa in preparation
for a US invasion when a kamakazi plane
appeared as if from nowhere diving
straight for the
ship it's estimated the indianapolis's
Gunners had just 15 seconds to react but
these men were the best of the best and
they managed to strike the plane with a
glancing blow knocking it off course to
crash harmlessly into the ocean
nearby that was the good news the bad
news news was that in the final seconds
of his life the Japanese pilot released
the single giant bomb that his plane was
carrying it was dropped at an altitude
of just 7.5 M so close it simply
couldn't miss as it happens it was
actually a little bit too close the bomb
did indeed find its Target smashing
directly into the deck of the
Indianapolis the trouble was it kept on
going smashing through the mes hole and
fuel tanks before punching an exit wound
in the bottom of the ship and detonating
in the water
Below had that bomb exploded a second or
two earlier it would have been curtains
for the USS indianaplis and this video
almost certainly wouldn't exist but the
ship survived just
about the damage was substantial and the
Indianapolis was forced to limp back to
the Naval Shipyard at May Island for
emergency repairs
as fate would have it that put it in
exactly the right place that's exactly
the right time to be assigned one of the
most important naval missions not just
of the second world war but of all time
over the previous three years a group of
rather clever scientist types have been
busy inventing what remains to this day
the most destructive weapon ever
conceived by man the atomic
bomb by the summer of 1945 the Manhattan
Project was almost ready to unleash this
new form of devastation on Japan in
hopes of ending the war for good two
bombs were already ready to go little
boy and fat man but both have being
built at Los Alamos in New
Mexico if they were to be dropped on
Japan as planned they first needed to
get them there and that wasn't as
straightforward as it might sound these
were highly experimental weapons the
firing mechanism in little boy had never
even been tested premature detonation of
these City killing bombs was a genuine
concern
to be on the safe side the wmds were
shipped dismantled with some parts going
by air and others by sea as the biggest
fastest and downright meanest ship in
the area at the time the Indianapolis
was entrusted with amongst other things
little boy's most important component
the enriched uranium core it's hard to
overstate just how important this cargo
was if you've seen the recent
Oppenheimer film you'll know that one of
the biggest challenges the Manhattan
Project faced was enriching enough
uranium to make a viable bomb that was
the whole marbles in the Fishbowl
business the fate of the world hung on
every single kilogram of fisal material
and yet when the USS Indianapolis set
out from Hunters Point Naval Shipyard in
San Francisco with the components for
little boy stored safely inside it was
carrying roughly half the world's total
supply of enriched uranium the price of
cargo was so classified even the ship's
Captain had no idea idea what he was
carrying the Indianapolis departed
Hunter's Point just 3 hours after the
first ever successful detonation of an
atomic bomb in the now famous Trinity
test as soon as they know the bombs were
viable they were on their way to the
tinian islands 1500 M south of
Japan the Indianapolis made this 6,000
mile journey across almost the entire
Pacific Ocean in just 10 days
the rest as they say is history on the
6th of August 1945 little boy was loaded
into the belly of a Boeing b29 super
Fortress called the anola gay and
dropped on the city of
harashima 3 Days Later fat man was
detonated over Nagasaki and 6 days after
that Emperor hito announced the
surrender of Japan to the
Allies for most people it was a day of
huge
celebration but not for the crew of the
Indian ianapolis Because by the official
end of the war most of them were already
dead after delivering its deadly cargo
to tinian Island the Indianapolis was
sent first to Guam and then onto the
Philippines but whilst on the way to the
island of late just after midnight on
the 30th of July the ship was cited by
the i58 a Japanese
submarine undercover of Darkness the sub
carefully maneu maned into the perfect
firing position then loosed six
Torpedoes towards its oblivious
Target Two struck home and the damage
was catastrophic near enough tearing the
ship in two 12 minutes later the mighty
USS Indianapolis was gone swallowed by
the inky Waters of the Pacific Ocean it
happened so fast approximately 300 after
close to 1200 men on board went down
with the ship the rest were pitched into
the endless expanse of the Pacific Ocean
a few made it into lifeboats but the
vast majority were simply cast a drift
in the water with only basic life
jackets to keep them
afloat alone in the darkness the
terrified men many of whom were badly
injured from explosions aboard the ship
could do nothing but wait to be
saved unfortunately rescue was very much
not on the way
at its height the US Navy fielded a
whopping 7,000 ships during the second
world war coordinating such a vast fleet
was a Monumental task and certain
Corners were cut just to make the whole
thing feasible in January 1945 a Pacific
fleets directive was issued stating that
the arrival of large combat ships no
longer needed to be reported
centrally unfortunately a rather
creative Port official at later decided
the new directive meant he didn't need
to report non-arrivals either which
meant that when the Indianapolis failed
to turn up as scheduled nobody raised
the
alarm that was a huge oversight but were
it not for another major balls up it
shouldn't have mattered after the
Torpedoes hit home the Indianapolis
followed standard protocols and
immediately sent out distress signals
calling for aid but the ship's radio
equipment had been damaged in the attack
and those signals were never transmitted
or at least that's what everyone
believed for more than 40 years but
documents Declassified in 1999 showed
that those distress signals were picked
up by no fewer than three different
radio operators all of whom attempted to
pass the Vital Information up the chain
of command remarkably all three were
ignored one of their commanding officers
was drunk one had done the military
equivalent of hanger do not disturb sign
on his door and the other believed the
transmission to be a Japanese
ruse all of which meant that
approximately 900 Sailors who' survived
the sinking of the Indianapolis were on
their own in the middle of the Pacific
Ocean 600 mil from the nearest
significant
[Music]
land the first Sharks were spotted as
the sun rose that very morning and the
following four days were punctuated with
blood curdling scream dreams as the crew
of the Indianapolis were picked off one
by one by circling oceanic white tips
and tiger
sharks it's hard to imagine just how
terrifying it must have been to be
hunted by 5 met sharks out in the open
ocean but the sad truth is there is a
lot more to worry about than just the
utterly terrifying local Wildlife this
was the height of summer in the Western
Pacific just 12° north of the equator
daytime temperatures were pushing 40° C
and the light from the sun reflecting
off the water rendered the men near
blind during the day and the nights
weren't any better with water
temperatures cold enough to induce
hypothermia there was almost nothing to
eat or drink and as severe dehydration
started to set in many eventually gave
in and just drank sea water which only
served to speed up their
demise one of the symptoms of extreme
dehydration is delirium and as the days
wore on many of the survivors began to
literally lose their minds suffering
Vivid hallucinations and in some cases
attacking or even drowning one
another and what little remained
developed brutal saltwater ulcers that
soon became infected but simply for four
full days these men experien conditions
that were right on the very brink of
what the human body can enjoy and
through it it all there were the sharks
always
circling in truth nobody knows how many
men were taken by the Tigers and white
tips that flocked to the sight of the
sinking in their hundreds conservative
estimates put the number at around 30
but some people believe it may have been
upwards of
150 perhaps it's for the best that we'll
never know for
certain by this point you might be
starting to wonder how we even know
about all of this I mean surely nobody
survived this living hell right well
were it not for a huge stroke of Good
Fortune they almost certainly wouldn't
have but on the morning of the 2nd of
August 3 and a half days after the
Indianapolis was lost a US spot plane on
a routine Patrol hunting Japanese Subs
saw a large oil slick spread out across
the ocean and what looked like men in
the water within it the crew reported
their findings to Shore and a few hours
later a sea plane piloted by Lieutenant
Adrian Marx arrived at the scene to
investigate further Marx brought his
Catalina flying boat in low to get a
better look and what he saw would Haun
him for the rest of his days hundreds of
American Sailors in the water a few in
lifeboats most floating in what were
essentially human rafts all were clearly
on the brink of
death Marx reported the situation at
once and finally realizing that their
10,000 ton $10 million warship had sunk
4 days ago without anyone noticing the
US Navy launched an immediate larg scale
rescue
effort having successfully completed his
mission Lieutenant Marx should simply
have returned to base but he didn't his
plane was capable of landing on water
but there was a strict standing order in
place never to land on the open ocean
the large swells made it far too
dangerous still markx knew it would take
some time for the ship based Cavalry to
show up and if there was one thing those
men in the water did not have it was
more time even from the air he could see
dozens if not hundreds of corpses
floating amongst the living not to
mention the ever circling sharks and the
blooms of red in the water that marks
the places they'd already struck and so
Marx asked his crew to take a vote
either head back to base or break the
standing order and attempt to land the
aircraft
to a man they voted for the
latter Marx brought the plane down
safely but it was a close run thing with
the aircraft bouncing precariously off a
3 and 1 half M wave before settling
unsteadily in the water Marx and his
crew began taxiing around amongst the
survivors pulling those in the worst
condition into the plane when there was
no more space inside the crew used
parachute cord to lash as many men as
they could to the wing
that night the rescue ships began to
arrive and the remaining survivors were
pulled from the water along with the
mutilated bodies of their fallen
comrades 1195 men had been on board the
Indianapolis when the torpedo struck
just 316 survived of that number 56 were
directly saved by Adrien Marx and his
crew that risky Landing in the open
ocean had rendered their plane unflyable
and once all the survivors had been
pulled from the water one of the rescue
ships the USS Cecil J Doyle sank it with
a volley from its
guns rather than Reed punishment for
breaking a standing order Marx was given
the air medal which is awarded for acts
of heroism during aerial
missions amongst the survivors of the
Indianapolis tragedy was the ship's
Captain Charles McVey II but in the
aftermath of the the rescue he was court
marshaled in charges of putting his ship
and crew in danger by failing to zigzag
a routine tactic used to confuse enemy
Subs in hostile
Waters McVey was convicted and the
decision ultimately left his career and
reputation in TAS he never truly
recovered and in 1968 he took his
life the US Navy lost almost 400 ships
during the second world war but McVey
was the only Captain to be court
marshaled for the loss of his ship due
to enemy action while some of the
survivors and relatives of those who
died blamed McVey for his role in the
tragedy the vast majority felt that he'd
been made a scapegoat and almost 30
years after his death that Viewpoint was
proven to be accurate by a sixth grader
Hunter Scott was inspired to study the
sinking of the Indianapolis after
learning about the story from our old
mate Quint whilst watching Jaws
showing a frankly unsettling level of
dedication and skill for a 12-year-old
Hunter pulled together an impressive
body of evidence suggesting that McVey
had indeed been treated
unfairly for example whilst it's true
that the indianapolus hadn't been
zigzagging when it was sunk it turned
out mcvey's superiors had failed to
mention to him that Japanese Subs were
known to be active along his route at
the time and zigzagging was only
required in hostile Waters
it also transpired that McVey had
requested a Destroyer Escort for the
journey especially one with submarine
detection equipment something the
Indianapolis lacked but that request was
denied supported by many Indianapolis
survivors Scott eventually took this
evidence and more before Congress and in
the year 2000 President Bill Clinton
himself exonerated Captain
McVey
the Indianapolis went down in some of
the deepest waters on Earth not too far
from the Mariana Trench and until
recently nobody knew exactly where the
wreck had ended up multiple Expeditions
have tried and failed to find the
Indianapolis over the years but it
wasn't until 2017 that a civilian team
funded by Microsoft co-founder Paul
Allen uncovered the final resting place
of the now legendary ship 3 and 1/2
miles beneath the surface of the Pacific
Ocean
the story of the USS Indianapolis is one
of both bravery and tragedy but it's
also one of Hope as of the recording of
this video precisely One Survivor of the
sinking is still alive veteran Harold
Bray in mid
2023 Harold wrote a letter to a Japanese
man he'd never met before Kido
kosimi the last surviving crew member of
the Japanese submarine i58
these two men had been sworn enemies on
opposite sides of a colossal tragedy but
Bray's letter wasn't one of hate it was
full of forgiveness friendship and
thanks a few weeks later KIRO Kumi sent
Harold an equally heartwarming reply a
reminder that even in times of
unprecedented political division we can
all find Common Ground as fellow
humans
thanks for watching just a quick word to
say that I couldn't make these videos
without the support of my patreon
members consider joining the exclusive
42 Discord Community by supporting me on
patreon it's a great place to discuss my
videos with like-minded individuals and
myself the Link's in the description but
if you don't want to or you can't join
my patreon then please don't worry a
simple like or comment to say thanks
would also put a huge smile on my face
thank you